Unser weltbild
erweitert sich von tag zu tag und das im wahrsten sinne des wortes jetzt ist ein neuer zwerg planet in unserem sonnensystem dazu gekommen
er könnte uns auf die spur von planet
x9 bringen wie das klick zum science fiction hier gibt es täglich neue science videos abonniert den kanal gerne herzlich willkommen
Das gibt sich alle tage ein neues werk planet in unserem sonnensystem und core plänen so heißt er ist ein ganz besonderer während pluto
seine umlaufbahn in einer entfernung von 30 bis 50 astronomischen einheiten um die sonne zieht macht das kopplin in
65 bis acht um
2.300 astronomischen einheiten seiner band ist so nicht nur extrem elliptisch sondern entfernt sich auch extrem weit von der sonne eine
astronomische einheit ist dabei die entfernung zwischen erde und sonne entdeckt wurde er dabei bei der suche nach planeten
respektive iks also dem unbekannten aber vermuteten riesigen gasplaneten weit draußen kreisen um unsere sonnengott den wurde erstmals
2015 von einem astronomie team entdeckt federführend waren dabei es gescheppert und chat trio von der
national university sowie david tholen von der university of hawaii
sie entdeckten goblin per zufall mit dem hawaiianischen teleskop subaru
nachdem sie ihn jetzt drei jahren beobachtet hatten und seine bahn bestimmen konnten bestätigten sie den fund von
2015 tg
387 goblin
katalogisiert wurde für seine bahn um die sonne benötigt jetzt fährt planet achtung rund
40.000 jahre sein durchmesser beträgt 300 kilometer und es ist nicht der erste zwergplanet denn bei der suche nach planeten
aufgespürt wurde zitat wir denken dass es tausende kleine körper wie
2015 tg 387 draußen einen rändern unseres
sonnensystems geben könnte aber ihre entfernung
macht die entdeckung sehr schwierig so einer der entdecker der vitol und doch diese entfernung hat auch einen entscheidenden vorteil
diese fernen objekte sind wie brotkrumen die uns so plane takes führen sagt gott shepherd ihre
umlaufbahn um die sonne wird nicht von den bekannten
bewusst jede beule in ihrer bahn könnte ein hinweis auf planet iks sein
der riesige gas plant den soll mehr als zehn mal mehr masse als die erde haben
aufgespürte zwergplaneten die so weit vom zentrum unseres
sonnensystems entfernt sind können so auf kleinen tricks hindeuten und zwar im wahrsten sinne des wortes umso mehr von ihnen entdeckt werden und ihre
umlaufbahnen berechnet werden können desto schneller könnte planeten aufgespürt werden
zitat je mehr wir von ihnen finden desto besser lernen wir das äußere sonnensystem
und den möglichen planeten kennen von dem wir glauben dass er ihre umlaufbahnen beeinflusst eine entdeckung die unser wissen über die evolution des
sonnensystems neu
definieren würde so scheppert wow das wird extrem spannend mehr über planet ins oder 9 gibt es hier dafür draufklicken planeten nachgewiesen
wenn ihr kein video zu diesem und allen anderen dem verpassen wollt dann abonniere ticks und vergesst die
glocke nicht und garantiert verpasst ihr kein video über den kostenlosen whatsapp
newsletter dafür ihr klingt nicht zur begrüßung gibt es ein kleines cooles goody bis dann
bleibt dran